I'm Grant Gustin and I'm here with
BuzzFeed to read your thirst tweets yes
I'm very nervous
this one's on top okay who is Grant
Gustin heart eyes emoji in math my
solution in history my king in art my
inspiration in science my oxygen in me
my everything
wow that was like a that was nice though
that wasn't that was a good start it was
sweet it didn't make me sweat
okay I love how the CW really went yes
we know that Grant Gustin is hung like a
damn horse and we're gonna show off that
bulge every chance we get thank you
if you think I'm attractive then I
appreciate that shut the up
he he
looks so damn sexy run me over please oh
my God I cannot breathe Thomas Grant
Gustin what the heck are you doing to me
it was in all caps I like toned down the
Caps as I went but um and I think they
were hyperventilating on the he's
um
wow this is an experience I haven't been
on Twitter in years
Grant Gustin had no right being that
sexy on Glee see
I was on plane
Grant Gustin being so hot is ruining my
life
she yeah I think she was distracted as
she was writing this actually so she she
missed a couple letters but I I know
what she meant and I'm sorry
if that's the case
I'd like to be a green screen so Grant
Gustin can step on me please
remember blue screen
this is the most bizarre experience
I've had today Grant Gustin looks so
good though oh my God choke me
what like it's just like quiet in here
too as I read all of these like it's
like I feel like um
doing something I'm not supposed to
Grant Gustin is officially the most
adorable human being of this world I
needed one to cleanse the palette so I
appreciate that one Grant Gustin could
spit in my eye and I'd probably say
thank you
I mean so this was before code so I
doubt they stand by this one
Grant Gustin can slushie me any day of
the week hashtag ding dong
um
okay
can Grant Gustin please make out with me
God damn he looks like such an amazing
kisser pucker those lips up against my
lips are those in caps as well so I gave
it a dramatic reading we're almost done
a part of me is like wow I really can't
stand man but then another part of me
hears I'm a Believer by Smash Mouth when
I see Grant Gustin cool
I've said this once and imma say it
again Grant Gustin gives off big energy
in what world
do I give off big
energy but I appreciate the thought
um last one Grant Gustin came to my
dream just to kiss me sad face
I don't know how to feel about that one
they tweeted it at 2 20 in the morning
also so they woke up after this happened
to tweet this
what a weird note to finish on thank you
guys my palms are sweaty my knees are
weak arms are heavy
I appreciate the tweets thank you
BuzzFeed please go check out our new uh
romantic comedy with Lucy Hale and lots
of dogs that's going to be a lot of fun
and I hope you enjoy it
foreign
[Music]